Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, the Stranger Things account
Just post a new Season 5 teaser.
We've already got a couple Season
5 teasers, so we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs,
and the Duffers have talked a little bit
about what's actually happening
during the season.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Netflix does have some other big stuff
coming out too, like the other Avatar
The Last Airbender,
live action series in after the strong
showing from the one piece
Netflix series,
I am a little bit more hopeful
that their live action
anime can be pretty decent.
The brand new Stranger Things
Season five teaser
is basically the utter destruction
of the scoops ice cream store in the mall
that Stephen Robin used to work at Zoomin
enhanced here you can spot the board
that she was using to make fun of them,
telling him all the reasons that he sucked
the reason why they released
this as a teaser is probably just a hype
Vecnas utter destruction of Hawkins
in the surrounding area
because basically he ripped a giant hole
through the entire town.
This now open to the upside down.
So like all of his creatures
are spilling out of it right now.
most of the damage in each of
the season so far has been localized
to a couple of specific areas in town.
Even when the reactor blew,
they thought that that's the hydro
inside the mall during season five.
look, that finger puppet
that was being controlled by Vecna,
They didn't blow out the entire mall
like it wasn't blown to smithereens.
They just damaged part of it.
the other big teaser is just for more.
VICKNAIR Coming for 11, just taunting her,
using his psychic powers,
They've already revealed
most of what's going on with him
just in general, his backstory
During season four, he's meant to be
the original Hawkins
experiment number one Dr.
Brenner found him an experiment
done on him
after discovering
he killed his entire family.
He had been locked up,
even though the police at the time
had blamed his father for the murders.
Dr. Brenner then discovered some of the
other children starting to develop powers
like 11 and brings them to the facility,
starts experimenting on them to
there were some earlier theories
about why the kids started
developing powers in the first place
in experiments that Dr.
Brenner was doing.
But because Henry, the Vigna character,
developed powers long before Dr.
Brenner's experiments started, it implies
everybody's sort of developing powers
for completely different reasons,
which they haven't fully explained yet.
Then Henry.
Victor's real name tricks
L1 into removing his power dampener.
He unleashes his full power, killing
most of the other children at the facility
in 11.
Uses her powers to push him into another
dimension, which becomes the upside down.
I know there were a lot of questions
about what was going on here,
basically the upside down used to
just be this sort of like formless area,
this other dimension
that he uses to form into the upside down.
The way you think of it, when you see it,
he basically used his powers
to control the organic life forms there
and reshape things to his will.
It's his obsession with Hawkins
that causes him to make the upside down
look like a copy of Hawkins.
here's the twist.
Oh, this is where we get to
the will character.
Because the devil was like, Oh, yeah.
Will's going to be critical
to defeating Becky during season five.
He'll be like
one of the biggest characters next to 11.
when Will Byers is captured by the
Demogorgon and taken to the upside down.
The moment that that happens,
the upside down
gets frozen in a Groundhog's Day
situation.
Trapped, repeating the same day over
and over November six, 1983.
That was the day that he was captured.
they haven't revealed exactly what will
like if he has any special powers
and what happened
when he entered the upside down
that caused it to be trapped
in a time loop.
but that will probably be the key to them
defeating Victor.
I like the idea that this character
actually births the events
and then restarts the events.
This kind of
I think it's kind of like a time loop
element that I think is very interesting.
the other big thing with Will's
character is they just said that
he would finally come out
to the rest of his friends,
like it's a big culmination of his arc.
Like it's all about this weird power
they've been teasing that he has
and he's kind of been in the background
the past couple of seasons.
Like they haven't answered
that many will questions
Then they also teased him
coming out to his friends in season four,
but didn't quite do that.
He'll finally do that during season five.
The other big thing they just teased
was Linda Hamilton joining
the series is a new character
with Arnold Schwarzenegger
because they're playing all the Terminator
tropes,
doing a big introduction for her.
that my old friend, a fantastic actress,
a bad ass, is joining
the Netflix family sent a video
and I want you to watch this video.
as Televisa.
I am Linda Hamilton and I am so excited
to share this news with you.
I'm joining the cast
for Stranger Things five.
I'll see you in Hawkins.
They didn't say exactly who she's playing,
but the show's
whole thing is playing on eighties
movies, TV shows and music.
The original Terminator movie,
still classic,
Even though technically
when people remember Linda Hamilton
is this badass from the Terminator movies,
is for her performance in Terminator two,
and that was released
in the early nineties.
So like,
we're spilling into the early nineties
here, even though Stranger Things
is mostly like an eighties kind of thing.
this also kind of happened
with the Guardians of the Galaxy movies,
like most of their music
wound up being seventies music,
but then they sort of
spilling into eighties
music in the later sequels.
right now,
my expectation,
without seeing more footage
or more teasers for her,
I think she'll play
one of the local people
who might have a connection with that
in the past before he became Becky.
In real life, she's a little too old
to play back in his sister
because the series takes place
in the eighties.
Vicknair was born in the forties,
meaning in present day
he'd be in his forties
and his younger sister
was much younger than him.
But she'll probably wind up
helping the group kill back now.
And the other big thing too,
they said the difference
between this season and previous seasons
is that the entire group
will be back together, whereas like
in season four, they were split between
Russia and Hawkins.
it's the same type of progression
that they had in the Game of Thrones
stories where, like all the characters
start relatively locally, close together,
then slowly,
as the series gets bigger and bigger,
they get pushed further and further apart.
Until towards the end of the series
I get to the climax.
They all start
to converge on each other again.
that's when shit really goes down.
Like the big final battle.
They're all there at the same place
They revealed the title of Stranger Things
Season five Episode one will be The Crawl.
Most people are assuming
this is a Dungeons and Dragons reference
and so much of the series
trades on Dungeons and Dragons tropes,
and it's all about dungeon crawling
like navigating through a dungeon,
which in the case of season five,
especially at the beginning of the season,
could just be them
navigating through all the craziness
that's happening here with the terror
in reality.
To the other dimension of the upside down,
there are
basically be like one of the first things
they need to address
at the beginning of season five.
Like, Oh my God,
there's a giant hole to another dimension
right through the middle of town.
basically a hell on earth situation,
kind of like a Ghostbusters situation
where the upside down
just comes spilling out into Hawkins.
They'll probably start the season with Max
still in her coma
at the beginning of the season.
The Devils are pretty clear,
though. She's still alive.
It's kind of like her consciousness
is just trapped outside of her body.
So maybe, you know, early theory
11 might wind up
using her powers to fix that situation
and make her conscious again.
her powers seem like they keep growing
season by season as she gets older.
And she's still a kid right now.
I think the idea is that ultimately
she'll be more powerful than Diana
if she isn't already.
part of the idea is that before
the beginning of season one, she push back
into the other dimension.
So she's already super powerful,
but she kind of created this mental block.
so that's why she wasn't quite as powerful
at the beginning of the series as she is
later in the series.
kind of like a grogu
you in Mandalorian situation
where like Grogu who trains
the Jedi Temple before Order 66,
then he experiences all this trauma
and cuts himself off from the force
and he becomes less powerful
until Luke Skywalker trains them again
and helps him
remember all these abilities that he has.
They didn't say that they would reference
Eddie like they would pay tribute to him,
but he's not coming back to life
or anything like that.
Maybe there'll be a flashback
or two with him, but for the most part
he's still meant to be dead
in present day.
There will also probably be more Doctor
Brenner flashbacks just to provide
more context and more untold story
for what's going on with Diana and 11.
the other big thing
the Devils are doing right now
is they're developing a spinoff sequel
show.
They didn't say which characters
it would follow,
but Season five is supposed to be
the end of the main story with 11.
In fact, now.
right
now, based on what Millie, Bobby Brown,
some of the cast have been saying,
it seems pretty clear
that the spinoff show won't be about her,
like she's ready
to move on to other stuff.
and it won't be about Hopper,
because David Harbor was also pretty clear
that he's also ready to move on.
so without more information about it
right now
my assumption is it'll probably be
about totally new characters
that they just teased during season
five people
we haven't really learned
that much about yet,
in some of the current main characters.
We'll just cross over onto that
occasionally, like Steve, Robin, Lucas,
Max, Nancy, maybe some of the others,
some of the manes, but not all of them.
Although I think that Netflix
would love to have Millie Bobby Brown
show up in the first episode just because
she's their big star for the main show.
even though the series
whole thing is trading on eighties vibes
and one of the big things in eighties
slasher movies is that they end
with some kind of jump scare
showing that the killer is still alive,
but it feels like they want to have
a legit ending for this storyline.
So they they want to end things with them.
Legit getting rid of him
Maybe not necessarily killing him,
but ending the threat of that note
for good. end,
I think the vast majority of characters
will get some kind of happy ending.
Like they won't fake out,
kill Hopper again.
Like he'll end the series being alive.
He'll get some kind of happy ending. 11.
We'll get a happy ending.
then they might tease some new threat
from some other kid that develops powers
or something like that,
something related to
all the different powers
that people are developing
that goes on to this spinoff series
They delayed season five
because of the strikes.
Most people assumed originally
it would release December 2024
because a while ago,
one of the cast members
said it would be out by his 22nd birthday
and that would put it right out
December 2024.
But that was before the strikes happened.
right now, I would not expect it
to release before summer 2025.
But once the strike stuff
gets figured out,
expect the stranger things
writers are teasing Season
five the same way they spent all that time
between season three and Season
four, teasing all the new episodes
with all kinds of information,
post all your predictions
in the comments below.
When do you think that they'll fix Max
in the first couple of episodes,
and how do you think they'll stop the
the character,
They'll probably release another teaser
for season five pretty soon.
Of course, they'll do more videos
when they release more footage,
more information.
My Ahsoka Episode
5 video We'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that video,
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for my one piece
Netflix Season 2 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!